is the Star Trek franchise really at
risk a slightly crazy rumor that I
didn't really believe might be coming
true
welcome to Sidetrack here Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of months ago I did a video
and I was talking about how potentially
Alex kurtzman's company secret hideout
might be being quietly removed from the
Star Trek franchise and that a source
that I've been speaking to for a while
keeps telling me and keeps insisting the
Paramount really don't want anything to
do with kurtzman anymore his contract
ends potentially tomorrow and that they
will not be renewing it now it's not
actually as simple as just sacking Alex
kurtzmann like a lot of YouTube channels
in the past have suggested Alex kurtzman
is the owner and the founder of the
secret hideout production company now
secret hideout currently is the primary
production company for the Star Trek
franchise so you can't actually sack
Alex kurtzman well you need to do is
remove Alex kurtzman's secret hideout
company as the primary production
company now Paramount can do that pretty
much at any point now at the moment they
had a contract with Paramount to produce
Star Trek but that contract ends in
April
they then extended that contract however
by two or three years but according to a
couple of sources that contract doesn't
actually stipulate Star Trek it just
stipulates that a secret hideout would
produce television shows and whatever
else for Paramount it was an exclusivity
and contract basically so that they um
secret hideout is exclusive to Paramount
it doesn't again according to sources
mention Star Trek
um I've actually had a look at the
announcements from that and to be fair
the announcements of the extension to
the contract don't mention Star Trek
either
so hmm
now news today has come out that
Paramount plus is actually going to be
merging with showtime in the United
States and the new channel or the new
entity is going to be called Paramount
plus with Showtime I tell you what
they've come up with the best names to
these things it's like Paramount plus
Disney plus oh God Netflix plus will be
next and the CEO of Paramount Bob
backish has already been talking about
several shows and things will be
canceled that there might be layoffs
within the Paramount plus and Showtime
organizations and that there will be
several announcements coming up in the
next few weeks as soon as those things
have been decided
so this seems to be quite a quick
decision but this comes from back again
what I was talking about in the previous
video Paramount oh a lot of money it's
something in the region of 16 billion
and that has actually reduced from
around 20 billion a couple of years ago
but at the end of the day Paramount plus
are struggling to manage that debt and
actually at the end of 2024 there's a
balloon payment due of around 5 billion
and at the moment they may struggle to
make that payment so Paramount plus
Paramount is a business entity
financially are in trouble and they may
need to sell certain parts of the
business to make the financial picture
make sense
so the rumor I was hearing was could
they actually sell one of the franchises
that is the most valuable Star Trek well
actually in Bob backish's statement he
did talk about that there will be
several programs that will be canceled
from the showtime and Paramount plus
um current library of Television but he
talked about that those shows made up
the bottom 10 of their viewing figures
now that wouldn't be Star Trek Star Trek
might not be the most valuable thing
they own or the most watched thing they
own but is it definitely up towards the
top the viewing figures have all been
very successful and it's done very well
strange new worlds in particular has
been very popular Prodigy has really
grown in popularity over time and lower
decks continues to do well discoveries
viewing figures
they can be argued about but the rest of
the stable of Star Trek shows have been
a reasonable success but that comes with
a caveat
Star Trek is also one of the most
expensive programs that Paramount
actually produces so could that
potentially put the Star Trek neck on
the chopping block
well I don't think so I think Star Trek
is one of the most valuable things
Paramount own and I don't think there
are any risk of selling it however I do
think that they're going to revert back
to partnership deals with other
streaming services for example what
they've done with Picard Picard
internationally will be available on
um Amazon Prime the day after it airs
and premieres on Paramount Plus
other networks obviously have
partnership deals including Nickelodeon
with Prodigy and I think they will
continue to do deals like that in the
future any Star Trek but do I actually
think that Alex kurtzman's secret
hideout could be removed from Star Trek
now Bob backish has already talked about
that they were in conversations with
their production companies about the new
way things are going to be done and I do
think that we could get news regarding
Star Trek in the coming weeks and months
we're going to have to wait and see I
think that the real thing though here is
when Picard ends we would have expected
an announcement about a another series
to replace it now we were expecting
something like section 31 or maybe even
a seven of nine reboot even though now
she's moved on to a different TV show
that seems less likely
so if there isn't an announcement in the
coming weeks following Picard then I
they actually think we'll have something
to worry about or I should say Alex
kurtman and secret hi that will have
something to worry about but however if
secret hideout announce that there is
another television show then that really
does show that Parramatta backing them
up
so basically there is a lot of problems
at Paramount there is a lot of debt just
like we said that Paramount plus has not
been the rip roaring success they were
hoping and that is force Paramount to
make this merger I do wonder whether the
success or failure of Picard season 3
will have a big impact everybody that's
seen it so far though says that it is
great and there has been a lot of effort
and a lot of advertising pushed towards
this new show so if Picard Series in
three is a success then maybe that will
be just enough to save secret hideout
moving forwards but I would almost
guarantee that any future production of
Star Trek will not have the very large
price tag that Discovery had
I can see them negotiating very hard to
bring in Star Trek at a much smaller
budget in the future I would love though
guys to know exactly what you think
about this news about the Powerman plus
merger with Showtime do you think that
puts Star Trek or any other shows on
Paramount Plus at risk and if it does
what do you think the future holds I'd
love to know exactly what you think if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification
really helps us out and as always if you
want to become a fully fledged side
tracker please consider hitting the join
button there are also links in the
description to our Stargate website our
sister Channel Sidetrack sides our
Facebook group etc etc please go check
them out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]